other houses chose dragons
krakens and lions for their sigils
we tallies took
the trout
that most terrifying us fish
especially when it leaps out of the
water
i suppose you don't have many options
when you live in the riverlands
could have been worse
we could have been
minnows or
wheat
after all we make a lot of it
though our land doesn't get as fertile
as ours just by water the old river
kings storm kings and the kings of the
rock
spilled blood here for thousands of
years
squabbling like children over a new toy
until the ironborn came and spanked them
with their axes
under harren the black their kingdom
stretched all the way to the god's eye
where they built the largest castle
westeros had ever seen
maesters teach that haran was a fool
but he had some sense
if you're going to enslave and torture
an entire people
you best have thick walls to hide behind
but the very day the last stone was laid
in harrenhal
targaryen landed in westeros
as soon as he saw aegon's host on the
horizon my ancestor edmund led the mass
desertion of riverlords to aegon's side
i doubt harren even noticed
the problem with huge castles is they
blind you to what's outside both by
their size and the arrogance they
inspire
not that the ironborn ever lacked for
that
they take pride in their ignorance of
every trapping of civilization
though any baker could have told them
that fire turned stone walls into an
oven
and so harren the black
finally lived up to his name and the
river lord swept the ironborn back to
the sea
in return for edmund's service
house tully was made aegon's new lord
paramount of the trident and all the
other lords had to swear us fealty
but old habits die hard
the riverlands are and always have been
the middle child of westeros
caught up in every fart from one lord at
another
my ancestors knew that for the tullys to
survive alliances must be made
our trout has swum up so many rivers
over the centuries and leapt onto so
many plates
that it's a wonder half the realm sigils
don't have fins by now
thus every tully child is taught
family
duty
honor
the tully words
aaron of hazor inherited a kingdom that
stretched from the iron islands to the
trident
too great a kingdom to rule from a
castle's shittiest pike
for 40 years his ironborn plundered the
riverlands for stone timber and slaves
to build the seat worthy of him
legend has it that masons laid the final
stone in erino on the very day that
aegon landed in westeros
could have been a divine owen
could have been the masons wants to [ __ ]
before the dragons got there
they weren't the only ones
at aegon's approach aaron's riverlords
revolted led by house charlie i thought
herron noticed
harrenhal could repel an army of a
million men
no ladder could summon its walls and no
ram could shatter them the castle was as
impregnable as an old mate's [ __ ]
aaron shot his gates around himself his
sons and his ironborn
and waited for aegon's army to drain
back into the muck
when aegon finally saw the monstrous
castle he asked for parley
herring granted it
valeria had been the greatest empire the
world had ever seen
aaron wanted to piss on its ashes
yield now and you may remain as lord of
the iron islands
yield now
and your sons will live to rule after
you
you see my army outside your walls
you see my dragons
what is outside my walls is of no
concern those walls are strong and thick
dragons fly
but stone doesn't burn
when the sun sets
your line shall end
aaron spat and returned to his castle
once inside he promised lands riches and
tallest daughters to whoever could bring
down aegon or his dragon
as the sun sank below the horizon all of
heron's men patrolled the battlements
hearing wings in every gust of wind
but the moon rose and sank
and no dragon appeared
while the ironborn were ringing the
battlements aegon drove his dragon
balerion higher and higher in the night
sky so that even the great castle of
herren hall looked like an ant hill
below them then they plunged straight
into the castle well inside the guarded
walls
the five towers of herren hall reached
towards aegon like a hand
valerian opened his mouth and bathed all
the fingers in flame
aaron was right
stone doesn't burn but men do
even when their ironborn
[Music]
the dragon blasted my ancestors into ash
that choked the survivors when they
screamed
harren soldiers leapt from the
battlements and died
they huddled against the walls and died
they fled across the yard and died aaron
and his sons took shelter inside the
castle
stone didn't burn
but as valerian blasted it with fire it
blowed white hot
the world's greatest castle became the
world's greatest oven
baking the last of those horror within
it
outside the castle walls the towers of
heron hall glowed red against the night
and began to twist and melt like five
huge candles with liquid stone trickling
down their sides like wax
the next morning aegon forged a new
riverlands
he named the rebel edmund tully as his
lord paramount of the trident and had
the other riverlords swear him fealty as
their new liege
for centuries house horror had
terrorized the riverlands
under house tully the riverlands would
at last return to peace and prosperity
after the castle cooled enough to allow
men inside aegon ventured into the ruin
he'd made of heron hall
he saw the ashen bodies the scorched
stone
and the mangled and melted swords of his
former enemies
to his men's confusion he ordered these
useless swords collected and sent to his
aegon fort
men have fought over the riverlands
since the dawn age
though that's to be expected of things
that rest below the neck
doesn't help that the riverlands are
between everything and everything else
the westerlands gold the reaches grain
the vale's rock and the north's
snow
house mud once ruled as the kings of the
rivers and hills
but after a thousand years their line
was exhausted and fell to the storm
kings who fell to the
ironborn i suppose after years of
drowning at sea
our rivers look pretty attractive to
that race of pirates never mind that
their monstrous castle harrenhal was too
large to staff and garrison
it turned out the ironborn wouldn't be
there long enough to bother
aegon targaryen landed to our south
and as had many before him
like the look of the riverlands
my ancestor edmund tully led the
desertion of riverlords to his cause and
was rewarded by getting to watch king
harren burn in his own tower
unfortunately
that's not all edmund got
house tully was named the lord's
paramount of the trident which means we
had to keep in line all those lords who
hadn't governed themselves for thousands
of years
we were now responsible for aiding the
malistas at seaguard against the pouting
ironborn whenever they got cheeky
for settling harrenhal on families
stupid enough to think its curse would
skip them
after devouring all previous families
for keeping the blackwoods and brackens
from wiping each other out and giving us
two more castles to deal with
for keeping the phrase in their place
and out of others pockets
for marrying off our sons and daughters
wisely enough so we didn't follow house
mud into
well
the mud
yet under the targaryens the riverlands
knew a piece we hadn't had for centuries
if ever
but like all good things
sooner or later it all goes to [ __ ]
and our [ __ ] had a name
aries targaryen
westeros has had its share of mad kings
but usually they had the sense not to
bully more than one powerful house at a
time
ares soon blundered into a triple
alliance
the north stormlands and vale rose
against him
but of course where do you think most of
the blood was spilled
my brother hoster guaranteed the answer
to that with a marriage of my niece to
eddard stark the warden of the north
at least hosta didn't send her to robert
so
the riverlands joined the war against
the mad king
and it was on one of our rivers that
prince rhaegar died
sealing the fate of his dynasty
robert was a great soldier
and a horrible king he died
and another war started
again the armies marched again the
riverlands burned
if westeros isn't careful pretty soon
our people will grow some sense and
abandon this place for a safer realm
like the dothraki sea
i joke of course
the riverlands are our home and gods
help us we love it
still as they say the king eats and the
hand takes the [ __ ]
the same is true of the riverlands
the seven kingdoms piss
and the riverlands change clothes